[Musique]
pour se saluer ils le font en chansons
chez eux
la musique est primordial elle s'invite
dans la cuisine de quoi faire réviser
adeline s'est pas de danse pendant la
cuisson de ses plats des mets servis ce
soir après le vide est une sorte de
récompense car avant il va falloir
soufflé près de quatre heures de
tendance est conne appelé le connais en
créole haïtien
[Musique]
ils sont chacun différent parce qu'ils
ont chacune notre cas la trompette on
retrouve toutes les notes d'un seul
instrument mais celui-là on a besoin de
chaque instrument pour faire une mélodie
donc à moi tout seul le bas fond de
mélodies j'ai besoin de musique et 7
mois pour pouvoir faire la mélodie parce
qu'on a chacun notre trafford et le
maestro du groupe en chef d'orchestre il
fait des recherches de musique populaire
ou locales à l'oreille il retranscrit
les sonorités sur un piano puis sur ce
tableau sous forme de notes
chacun apprend sa partition et son
passage dans la musique
si le goût d'eau et d'égouts me alors
j'ai eu le dessus et je dois attendre
comment toi élevé pour votre maman c'est
pas comme ça on joue tu joues dounot en
alsace c'est qu'on piano il faut pas
faire des fausses notes
il faut suivre la rigueur tout le monde
s'est tu bref avant ton tour ont fait
des fausses notes c'est pas beau il faut
aussi s'harmoniser avec les autres
instruments comme les tambours ou encore
ce double bass en pleine rénovation
qu'est ce que vous êtes en train de
faire je vais pas fonder sur quatre
morceaux pour les basses il faut qu'ils
soient du patois iggy équipe a peu varié
nauplie france a semé
l'âme du groupe est né avec leurs
instruments traditionnels
voici le message qu'ils veulent faire
passer pendant le carnaval en martinique
c'est d'abord dans leur quartier aux
terres sainville qu'ils se font entendre
pour eux défilé pendant ces festivités
participent aux reflets de la culture
antillaise